this room has been straight up torturing me
for the last six months
and I won't lie, I got a bit over it at times
but today I'm happy
I'm fkn elated actually because I can
officially say she's done
this is our very mid-century split-level dual lounge
which is another way of saying it's two rooms in one
with a lot of different surfaces and spaces to think about
so I've tried to make it functional first and foremost
hence why there's a bar in it
I've tried to use colour both to delineate the two spaces
but also to tie them together
I leaned on white primarily and one half of the room
because I wanted the view to speak for itself
and I wanted the darker half of the room to feel cosy
sophisticated and elevated
we've got a mix of old and new
some objects are upcycled
and some are from each of our parents or grandparents
who aren't related by the way
and after a really long time of struggling in the space
I'm actually quite pleased at how it's come together
I'm sure you'll let me know what you think
actually I just realised we're not quite done
cause one day that fireplace will get replaced
but good enough is good enough
and that's enough for now